the Oscar nominations were announced  this morning everything was going very  smoothly until and this is true Academy  president Cheryl Boone Isaacs  mispronounced the name of  cinematographer dick Pope was kind of  embarrassing check it out for  achievement in cinematography the  nominees are dick poop dick coach mr  Turner well it's unfortunate a laugh at  that you're hearing laughter of  compassion but you know it's too bad I  think that that flub she made really  made her lose her composure because it  all went rapidly downhill after that  take a look this is too bad for  performance by an actor in a supporting  role the nominees are robert depuis in  the jet blue pop in the new foot mark  Tupelo in boot camp hoop hoop simmons in  at hoop North Loop in Birdman  [Applause]  you